[Music]
Vanessa Bryan got tattoos to honor her
late husband Kobe Bryant and her 13 year
old daughter Gianna back in February and
on Wednesday she shared a few videos
from her ink sessions on Instagram the
38 year olds hit up tattoo artists Nikko
Hurtado who made a house call to ink her
up with two different tats first
attribute to Gianna on her wrist she
captioned the clip quote shout out to
Nikko Hurtado for coming over and
helping me get my GG's sweet message
transferred on me but it's unclear
exactly what the message says next up a
tribute to Kobe on her neck well I
wanted my booty sweet message
transferred on me Vanessa didn't reveal
specific details about the body art like
what they say but it's clear they're
meaningful to her Kobe and Gianna along
with seven others died in a helicopter
crash in Calabasas California On January
26 a few of Kobe's friends like LeBron
James and Anthony Davis also got tattoos
to honor the NBA legend after Vanessa
shared the throwback clips on Instagram
some of her famous pals showed her love
in the comments Khloe Kardashian writing
so special beautiful
Lala Anthony and Tia Mowry also showed
their support while Gabrielle Union
simply wrote love the latest posts come
just a few days after vanessa honored
her late daughter on what would have
been the day of her middle-school
graduation she shared this sweet pic on
instagram writing i love you forever and
always
i'm so proud of you love mommy back in
april ET spoke to another basketball
great magic johnson who shared an update
on how vanessa and their three girls
Natalia Bianca and Capri are doing
their life there they're having a good
time and I think Kobe would have wanted
that right for them to go on live a
great life and and just have enjoy
yourself and Vanessa's the reason for
that and I think she's got a great
village around or people around her to
give her that support part of that
support system vanessa is close friend
lale anthony who told ET she couldn't be
more proud of her I talk to her every
single day
and just you know continue to pray for
her and stay positive for her she I tell
her every day she's the strongest woman
I know and I'm really really proud of
just how she's handling everything and
just want to continue to be there you
know as much as I can for her as a
friend she's just an amazing and amazing
human being just just amazing